NBC Sports Bay Area's ray righto here on
the show how are you Raymond
just for the record yes I'm only
interrupting my viewing of England
Colombia for three people
yes my wife mm-hmm one of my two
children which of your children well ray
ray I will keep you up to speed I'm sure
you're watching and just as I am well if
there's a greater yes yes yes the
Colombia coaches he's definitely thirsty
how the Warriors taking all the the
banter in the in the Twitterverse or the
sports universe that this is unfair the
boogie cousins signing is unfair ray and
the Commissioner needs to stop it they
are cackling like drunks kid Nick they
couldn't be less interested
I mean they've done one of the weirdest
things ever and not and I don't mean
like you know boogie cousin is a
difficult guy to deal with that's not
where I'm going they actually spent 22
million dollars to give a guy five
million and 60 million to the league for
the right to rehabilitate a guy's career
so that he can leave and try to beat
them next year that to me is that's the
stunning part of all this because
they're not resigning him I mean you
know which which which player between
klay Thompson and draymond Green do you
get rid of to keep him unless you're
planning to become the first team ever
to pay more in luxury tax than in actual
salaries because that's where they stand
with the salary cap correct with them
yeah that's why they have to pay twenty
two million dollars to sign boogie
cousins cousins gets five million in
change but because they are so far of it
because they are in the repeater tax
they have to pay 3.75 dollars every
dollar they spent from this point
forward
so basically 5.2 becomes 21 or 22 I but
I don't want to do the math again my my
brain will bleed but that's pretty much
it
I mean they literally they said we're
going to save your career in exchange
for three three months of really hard
work and then you can go somewhere else
and try to beat our brains out next year
now what they have done this had LeBron
not arrived in in in Los Angeles is
there any sense of striking back and
staying a step ahead like why why I
guess would they do something like this
I think the timing suggests that but I
think they might have done it anyway
because the one thing that the Warriors
do that is reminiscent of the old
Steinbrenner Yankees is that for the
time being
money is literally no object and so I
think when cousins people called called
Bob Meyers and said hey could you fit
him somewhere on your team because he's
available I mean and they reached out
and found out that nobody else was
interested so this was sort of you know
DeMarcus Cousins gambling on himself and
Bob Meyers thought about it for a minute
well let me run it by my Council of
Ministers which is basically his best
players and they all loved the idea so
he basically ran up to Joe wake up and
said hey I found a way to blow 22
million bucks what do you say until wake
up succumbs not find it important you
know it's just investors money and it
and they did it in a hurry I don't know
that it was a response to LeBron shining
in LA I don't think that you know
dampened their interest in doing it but
you know I think they would have done it
anyway the added benefit of watching the
rest of the league's shoulders just
droop and go we're screwed for all time
it's probably just an added benefit yeah
I mean there it there is kind of like a
trolling aspect of it but you know ray
Ratto NBC Sports Bay Area here but what
are they supposed to do just sit back
and let the rest of the league catch up
to them and if they do have an ownership
that says okay III know it's gonna cost
us three times as much to spend to
feather the nest of our competition into
a luxury tax Kitty then so be it but
we're gonna
in you winning basketball games and
championships and continue the dynasty
and and let everybody else [ __ ] and
moan about it essentially I mean that's
that's what's wrong with that no
nothing's wrong with it is what every
franchises fanbase which is their local
billionaire would do and look what when
when the price went when it all went it
all and and it's going to end without
crash I mean I hope warrior fans will at
least recognize that a the crash was
inevitable but the ride was way worth it
it's basically like putting people on a
roller coaster and saying at some point
the brakes are gonna fail and you are
all going to plummeted it'll gonna drown
but the ride will be hilarious how does
that sound
I guess well why does it have to end
because I mean the only way it ends is
if somebody demands that they get maxed
out and in a way that breaks up the team
and I mean why wouldn't they want to
play in a beautiful new building in San
Francisco California and be part of that
one of the best dynasties maybe to play
the game next to the Celtics of the of
the 60s right and and why wasn't the
reason why wouldn't reason why yeah the
reason might have to end is because you
it can't recreate Stephon curry and he
is the engine around which everything
else operates and he is one of those
rare commodities of a superstar who owns
the room that he dresses in with his
teammates without having to act like he
owns the room it's the reason why he
gets along with draymond Green and klay
Thompson and Kevin Durant and all the
other disparate personalities and why he
can sign on so cheerfully to DeMarcus
Cousins without a thought because
basically he is like Switzerland with
with atomic weapons is you know he
doesn't exist on perks that most
superstars do but the ones he doesn't
sit on he insist on with a smile and
everybody gets along with that so
there's less overt agenda laden egos who
this team in most and when he goes I
don't think you can replace that because
I don't think most people operate that
way they like voting their stock and
curry doesn't do that or at least
doesn't do it in a way that irritates
the other powerful players on this
roster so when he goes they're gonna eat
they're gonna have to figure out a way
to find somebody who is a generational
player who was also cool with everybody
plays with yes I think that's the one
thing they can't replace yeah and and
who doesn't mind
Durant joining the team and winning both
NBA Finals MVP s as soon as he joins the
team or a rat o NBC Sports Bay Area here
on the Rich Eisen show so then let's try
and find a Fisher let's try and find the
crack because that was what what what
West had to say after the championship
was won saying that you you have no idea
what we've been dealing with here all
season long and everybody from from the
coach to draymond Green essentially
saying we dealt with a lot any idea what
what was going on in that locker room
that they were dealing with few weeks
later yeah right yes Julia was
threatening people with guns is that
true no okay no I think then the general
impression is that a couple of players
were having some personal things away
from the basketball that were bothering
them early and then when curry went down
I think there was a little bit of
friction over you know Durant's plays
whether he should take over whether they
should become more of an isolation team
and I think they struggled to sort of
operate you know in Curry's absence and
I think that's another way that you know
that not having curry will affect this
team adversely what that when when he
retires it's that he really greases
everybody's peers on the floor and I I
think you know it's it's one of those
things where you get personalities and
you put them together for ten months a
year every day for four years
people start get a little cranky with
each other but it was nothing from
remember I've been able to find out
there was nothing like genuinely overt
it just
it's a pressure everyday it's you know
time commitments everyday it never goes
away
you know there's summer weather should
have it off and you know they're getting
sent to China to stir up more money for
the organization it's it's a job it's a
basketball job that doesn't stop when
the game ends and I think that just
creates its own sort of pressure that I
think you know starts to gnaw on people
but I don't think it was you know I I
don't think it was cataclysmic I think
you know there were times when when you
know Steve Kerr would say things to try
to motivate them in public and they
didn't like that either I mean it it's
stuff that I think happens on every team
but because it rarely happens on this
one it feels like more than it was
well that in the petroleum gun thing all
right I appreciate it it's still nil-nil
we didn't miss any scoring during this
conversation between Columbia and in
England but I am wearing a Mexican KITT
with a Mexican flag on my cheek just to
paint the the picture because I lost a
bet here on the show oh I was kind of
hoping that you just forgotten who was
playing today no no that knows no such
case but you may you may resume your
World Cup watching I really appreciate
the time as always Raymond yeah this is
big yeah this is basically the only
thing that separates us from the animals
because in all other ways frankly there
should be a bounty on us
take care Ray have a great fourth you
gotta at Ratto NBC yes the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience